エンディング
アキナちゃーん!アキナちゃんてばー!
あの、あきなちゃん
あら、豊臣くん
あれ、機嫌悪いみたいだな
あ、あきなちゃん、わざとぶつかったわけじゃないんだよ
だから
豊臣くん
え?
留年したんだって
そっか、僕留年しちゃったのか
私たちはもう社会人
いつまでも遊んでいられる大学生のあなたとは人種が違うのよ
でも私たちって
やあ豊臣 留年おめでとう
仕方ねえよな ジャンソーがよいの毎日を繰り返してちゃ
単位取れねえのは当たり前だって
お前らその格好は
俺たちはとっくの昔に麻雀から足洗ったぜ。
でもって、春からは社会人一年生ってわけだ。
おめ、チートばかし気づくの遅かったようだな。
そ、そんなバカな!
つくづくあなたには愛想が尽きたわ。
さよなら、豊臣くん。
-バイバーイ。-あきなちゃ!
あきなちゃ。
これからは同級生でんな。仲良いやりまひょ同輩。同々輩。これからは平等でんな。平等や。平等や。
師匠、わての顔、なんかついてますか?
いや、俺、ゆうべどうしたっけ?
あら、なんも覚えとらんのですか。昨日は渋谷でやけ酒飲んだじゃないですか。
やけ酒、俺が、なんで?
留年したから。
俺やっぱり卒業できなかったんだ。
当たり前ですがな。師匠は3年から4年に上がれなかったんですよ。卒業なんて。
なんだって。
だから4年に。
その前。
師匠。
もう一度。
もう一度
バカ言ってないでバイト行きますよ
いらっしゃいませ
おいコーヒーちょうだい
はーい
おしぼりもらえる
はいはい
豊臣くん留年したって聞いたから落ち込んでるかと思ったけど結構元気そうじゃない
いやー今朝少しおかしかったんですけどね
大丈夫ですやろうか
はいピンチをお願い
はい、ビンチ入りまーす!
トン4曲、ちょうど原点ですね。
よーし、僕が親だな。
なるべく早い手作りを心がけなくては。
何を切ろうかな。
まずは、リャンソパーソの整理というところか。
おい、メンバー、早くしろい。
あ、はい。
とりあえずこれ切って、様子見だなっと。
なっと!
あら、いきなり裏目っちゃったわね。
酸素を引けばどうてことないっす。
想像の流れだな。瓶酢のペンちゃんを落としていこう。
平気、平気。まだ序盤だし。
そうだ、悲観することはない
まだ2、3、4の3色がある
ここは早めにドラ切りだ
またドラなんか持ってくるな
つか、切るとくる
まさにキルクルの法則
あ、それぽん
今問いつったんだ
そ、そんなー!
なんてつかんこなの?
わーい
うっばそのふりてんじゃー!
50目で一数ピン、うっばそのふりてん作って、2、3、4のソースの一面通捨ててる
しかも本来といつのドラマで泣かしている、まずい
フッ、ピンチが帰ってくるまでに何とかしなくちゃ。
な、なんだ?なんだ?
ま、まだ、もうちょっと入っててもらえますか?お客さん。
ああ、そういえば、まだ少し残量感があるな。
でしょ?この際ですから、すっきりさせちゃいましょう。ね、ね?
誰ですか?
あんたが切る番だよ
はいはい
10の山が1つと2の山が1つ
全部で12
勝敗しとる
なんとかバレずにこの曲を切り抜けなくちゃ
どうしたのバイト君顔色悪いよ
なんでもなんでもないです
昨日からちょっと歯が痛くて
あれあれ上相撲だったっけか
お客さんあるんですよ全自動宅だと
たびたび上相撲と下相撲がずれることが
そ、そだったんすか?
と、とにかくこの曲は徹底してベタ折りだ!
筋!
何事もなく過ぎさればそれでいい
どう?いや、苦しい形なんだよな
トイトイトン、ドラーサン、ハネマー
はあ、すっきりした
ちょっと待った!
あ、なんだ?な、なんだ?なに?
す、すいません!お客さん!ドアの立て付けが悪いみたいで!
ドア!
よーし!これを上がればチャラだぜ!まだ50名!勝ったも同然だ!
ありゃー!
考えてる。アンナさんはノータイムでツモ切りよね?
いや、たぶん、筋の悪い師匠のことやから、三腕カンするんじゃ。
まさか。
勝手に想像すんじゃねー!
いいから見てろよ!この場合、プロだったら、これぎりだ!
つ、鋭い!
三腕ぎりだと、一数中腕、兩腕の四面待ちやが、九腕なら一数腕、兩ウーパー腕の五面待ち!
さ、さすが師匠!
どうだ、少しは見直したかい?
そんないつも尊敬してます、師匠
賢明な視聴者の皆さんには、彼が何を引いたのか、もうお分かりでしょう
どっちだー!
ロー、綿炭品3色、発刊目。
いやー、ローもローもさーてと。
お客さん、トイレ帰りで気分悪いでしょう?はい、おしぼり!
どうも、どうも、どうも。
はい、お茶とコーヒー、大盛り!
どうも!
それに、ヨーグルト、ジョワッチ、サービス!
なおかつ、卵に火をつけて!
続きましては、マッサージ!
マッサージか?
一つ積んでは、母のため。
ふい!
二つ積んでは、父のため。
そして、花束贈呈!
なんか悪いな、僕だけこんなものを。
いえいえ、ほんの気持ちですから。どうかお幸せに。
おお、これはすごいダブリーだな。
地獄のジャンボーイ、トヨタミ。
彼にピンチを頼んだ者はすでに死んでいる
おいピンチだな
はいただいま
トヨタミ君麻雀の方も留年ね
アンダーアンダーアンダー
最後の一発になっちまったべ
あああそこ違う
あああった
ごせいもしちまっただ
ツダー!ダメ!
こんやくしちゃおうか!
アケチ君!
まずー
あんただれ?どういうこと?
どういうことって、愛が冷めたっちゅうかなんちゅうか
このいい加減男!
もっと話し合う時間があった!
ほら行けまくれ
5-6だ5-6
裏切っちゃった
今月のバイト代これでパーだぜ
バカ野郎気をつけろ
何よ
てめえこそ
あけち
しんたろう
あんた、お前ら!
あ、やっす!
何、二人ともとんがってんだ。
ついてねえな。
私生活にまで不協の波が押し寄せてきちまってるぜ。
そんだな、パチンコはまるでてねえし、
女にはふられるし。
はあ。
こうなったら、いっちょ、役払いに行くか。
ああ!
えー、ベンチいかがっすか?ダイソーの御用はありませんか?
師匠、どうしたんすか?ニコニコしちゃっておかしいわ。
何かいいことでもあったのかな?
いや、別に。
教えなさいよ。
分かった。さては師匠、アキナハンとデートですやろ。
え、わかる?
しかもアキナちゃんの部屋で二人っきり。
え、えへへへへへ、そ、そんな。
BGMが途切れた途端、見つめ合う二人。
トヨタミ君。
アキラちゃん!
ウチュー!
チュッ、チュッ、チュッ。
ああ、いや、バカ!やめてよ!
トヨタミ君、あそこのタッグからお呼びがかかってるわよ。
ぜひ、あなたと打ちたいって。
あ、はい。
やめてください。え、そこまでするんですか?
そこまでするんだよ。
えええええええ!
やあ、トヨタミ。
元気だったか?
久しぶりだな。
あー、僕そろそろ時間ですんで、上がらせてもらいます。どうぞ他の方とごゆっくりお楽しみください。
はい、待ちな!
お前、友達がわざわざ訪ねてきてやったのに、その態度はなんだ!
ちった、友情ってもんを大切にしろよ。
デートが。
さあ、ちーちゃんは誰だ?
おい、ちーちゃん!
俺んとこ、ちーちゃん!
やった!
俺、ちーちゃーん!
ちかちゃーん!
何、まだ負けたわけでねえの!
もう少し、お静かに願えますか?
はい。
あんた?
他のお客様のご迷惑になります。
なんだと、トヨタミ!おめえいつからそんなに偉くなったんだ!
まあまあ。
ここは静かに打とうじゃないか。
店員気取ってるのも、今のうちだぜ。
たまりにたまった鬱憤をぶちまけてやる。
はーい一発だぜ
もろひっかけこの街で一発出してくれんな豊臣だけだぜ頼りになるな
お客様それチョンボですね役がない
ああバカよく見ろよリーチだよリーチ
リーチとは発声と同時に先天棒を出し
パイを90度横に曲げて初めて成立するのです
発声もなく先天棒も出されていないものはリーチとみなされません
何固いこと言ってんだよ
だいたいお前が静かに打てって言ったからオラ
いや一理あるな
オラもトヨタミが正しいと思う
チョコ大訓論
お前ら
そうかあったよ
こいつも こいつも ついてねえからって ギスギスしちゃって
ほらよ
いいじゃん この野郎!
ほら!
これなら 文句ねえだろ!
おかげでーち
な なんだこいつ
自分で言ってるそばから 展望出してねえんべやんの
バカなやつ
あらー
こいつは切れないなぁ。
何すんだ!お前リーチしてんだろうが!
困りますね、お客様。先ほど言ったじゃありませんか。
リーボーの出てないものはリーチと見なされないんですよ。
何!?
私のは出てないでしょ?したがってリーチじゃない。すなわち手代わり自由自在と。
こいつ!
おっとぉ、いいとこ引いた!
追っかけにーち!
さぁ、今度は本物だよ!
ちくしょう!そんなもんありんか?
おーわりさ!
ラーン!
ひょえー!
ちくしょう、やってらんねーよな、まったく。
お客さん、縦膝は困ります。
あんた、残駄を!
打敗はおとなしく。
ああ、ギスギスしてやがる。
ああ、どうすっかな。
泣くべ。
お客様、一度ツモハイに触ったら泣けない決まりです。
何言ってるだ。おら触ってねえだ。
鑑識。
はは。
警部間違いなくやっさんの指紋です
どうですかこれでもまだ触ってないと
そりゃ前の曲に触ったやつだよ
語るに落ちたなやすべ
あれ
全自動は色の違う2種類のパイが交互に出てくる
したがってトン二曲の時点では
あんたこの色のパイにはまだ触ってないはずなんだよ
しまった
そっかそれほどまでにそのチューンをポンさせたくねえだな
ルールですから
わかった積もればいいんだろ積もれば
つのげる
ポン
よく考えたら今トンの三曲でねえが
指紋がついていてもおかしかねえだよな
ふぅ、遅い、たく遅い
ちくしょう!
出た、2600
ち、え?
ん、いらねー
ラーン!
ちゃんた本逸ナン、マンガン!
うまい!
この調子なら豊臣くん、うちのジャンスを着てから初のトップ取れるかも!
ま、まさか
この曲は流れだな
よし、リーチ
あ、なんだ?リーチってお前
ワンパイまであと4枚
つまり1回しかツモはないんだぞ
違うわ、このリーチはただのリーチじゃない
じゅ、16面待ちリーチ
あんた?16面待ち?
ママさん、大丈夫だか?
オイラの捨て牌をよーく見てみな
どれどれ
アアア!
ああ、あったくもう、なにさ?電弾を決めたって。
アアアアア!
あと1回で流し弾がんだべ!
しかもリャン・ウーパー・ワンの三面待ち!
八百中杯十三枚と合わせて史上最強の16面待ちに来ちゃうけ!
おら!誰か泣け!一品だ!
ダメだ!泣けねえ!なん泣け!
積もられちまうだ!キューピン泣いてくるのほう!
よっしゃー!
何!?
詰まった!流しマンガン!
ママさん、このジャンソー、流しマンガンのルールあったっけ?
え?
ああ!ないない!全然ない!忘れてた!
はいご覧の通り我が一番館では流しマンガンは役として採用しておりません
ごめんなさい先週決めたばっかりなの
その店のルールを知らねえメンバーなんかに打たれると客が迷惑すんだよな
俺たちとしてはちょんぼ代もらってもいいくらいなんだぜ
まあ俺たち館代だから今回だけは多めに見てやるべ
つかんぽ
ロン7700
一つ人より月はなし
ロン12000
二つ不幸な星のもと
ロン18000
三つ見る夢人並みの
四つようやくてんぱって
五つ遺産でおっかげリーチ
六つ無惨なあたりはい
ロン!ロン!
ロン!
ママさん、トリプルロンは?
もちろん、あるよ!
ズガーン!
寒い日が続きます。みんな、風邪なんかひかないでね。
さて、木枯らし舞う寒い冬の夜、ひとり寝の豊臣くんが見た夢は?
次回、南極図鑑!なりきん図鑑!きっと見てね!
眠っちゃ、いや!
ご視聴ありがとうございました
リーチをかける
飛べてくるんだ
スカント
いかねばならぬのだ
リーチ
勝負かけたら
情けない
君は
僕のワンカンソロよ
スカント
幸せ掴もう
みんな サクッ
ああ
ここは三面町どころ
行くぞ カンちゃん
徳島そこの席が肌
スーモー25は天狗にやりづいて
勝手飲み越すビールがうまい
スカット!
お酒はいどっちがけ
スカウト スカウト スカウト スカウト